had an upper class today best way I
found is you create a calendar so you
create a calendar and you put in your
calendar the habits that will lead you
towards success right so you have ideas
for what you want to create amazing none
of that happens until you create into
actions right it's the actions and the
habits that you do every day that lead
you towards your dreams otherwise it
just remains hopes and dreams so this
would not be happening if it was not in
my calendar but I had to schedule this
in I want to walk outside for three
hours a day great well when is that
going to start if I did not put in my
calendar I would not be out here doing
this and so step one is you create a
calendar that maps to your Ambitions
that are the habits that if you follow
those habits you'll move closer to your
goals your business goals your personal
goals your relationship goals your
Finance goals are you doing the work is
it in your calendar right step one and
then step two is you teach yourself that
you do what's in your calendar we're
eliminating the thought process behind
it because procrastination is your brain
gets in the way right your brain is
telling you oh I'll do it later I can't
do it now I'm not smart enough or I mean
to do some research first like your
brain gets in the way so the way the
shortcut the brain is you create the
calendar and then you do what's in your
calendar need motivation watch this top
10 would believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn from me and my team's
take on my top 10 rules of success
enjoy
so you create the calendar when you're
feeling bold and courageous and you come
with a new goal it's like so exciting
great don't just sit in that excitement
and don't just go researching plop in
your calendar how you're going to keep
this consistently happening in your life
so that you don't just get this
momentarily burst of energy and then you
fall back down
right so you put it in your calendar how
you're going to sustain this action how
I got this I was at an event uh two
weeks ago and I got this idea that I'm
going to start walking outside and it
started off as two hours a day then
lastly became three hours a day this
week continuing three hours a day
it's great to get an idea out of how
many times you got an idea at an event
or watching a video you get some great
idea awesome if you just do it once it's
not enough how do you maintain the
consistency how do you turn into a habit
don't wait for you to feel motivated it
has to go into your calendar so I pop
this into my calendar and then when I
wake up and I look at my calendar I do
it to my calendars so you eliminate the
brain from the process and therefore
eliminating the procrastination so you
create your calendar when you're feeling
bold and courageous and on top of the
world and Unstoppable
maybe like right now you're getting some
energy go put something in your calendar
and then when you wake up you do what's
in your calendar do those two things
it'll change your life rule number two
is learn about marketing my question is
marketing last year I did an online
somatic prep work and really know how to
Market and I only have one person show
up people don't know who I am yet so you
have any tips on how to Market in person
for Live Events and online so the
fastest way if you want to fill it up is
through Partnerships unless you've got a
big ad budget that you're gonna start
spending it's Partnerships whose space
are you doing it out of the gym I go to
can you put flyers up in the gym yeah I
can the people who are going to come to
your event they're paying you to come to
the workshop yes could the gym help
promote it and take a cut yeah I'm sure
I can work with her yeah you can email
it to their list then they get a
commission okay yeah maybe you're going
to need a commission maybe they'll just
do it for you yeah can you go and be at
the front of the gym for the week before
and talk to people that come in and have
flyers and share about the workshop that
you have coming up have an announcement
board you can put something up on it's
like how can we use the location to help
promote because there's foot traffic
coming in every day people coming to the
gym every day how can we help get our
message to them and incentivize the gym
maybe they do it because they just love
you maybe they do it because you're
you're renting space maybe they do it
because they're making a cut all of the
instructors all of the the people who
are you know personal trainers there
getting to know them so that they're
saying in the class potentially that
you've got this thing coming up
so that's the easiest one next you go to
all of your the local media
the local newspaper the local Facebook
groups the local whatever and get to
know the reporters so you're in Eureka
California yeah great yeah like there's
some newspaper for Eureka California
that that
you know you know I saw you trying to
get into the LA Times
you're trying to get into the Eureka
newspaper okay it's a lot easier yeah so
what reporter is talking about the
events in Eureka right now get to know
her or him and let them know that you've
got because your ideally this is an
ongoing thing it's not just this one
event yeah a weekly event
right so build up those connections help
rule number three is leave your comfort
zone self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people will let you off the hook
people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
could have done it you know like that's
the worst feeling in the world that you
could have done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments rule number four
is tap into your heart I think I am much
more logic driven when I look at like
evaluation so try I I have a lot of
heart but I tend to make these take a
bigger decision with logic so trying to
even though you say failure it's a
little bit challenging for me to make
that switch it's the only thing that
matters though for this
like this is the this is the ultimate
skill to learn
for big decisions like this it doesn't
mean like the concern then becomes well
we get too emotional and then I just do
whatever comes into my head and with a
little no you're not you're never going
to be that guy you're never going to be
Reckless
yeah but for big
imagine if you're getting married
you better love her
as opposed to well logically you know
like it makes sense
I think it's probably both of those
right but it better be allowed
expectations
it better be a lot more on the love than
on the logic
uh yeah like you see a lot of the guys
who have been married for a while like
oh my gosh I hope he gets this like I'm
not married yet so that's one of the
reasons like this is this isn't this is
a skill set to start to trust your heart
which you need you need both
there are some people who only listen to
the heart and are like doing all sorts
of crazy things and never say
consistently anything and and never
listen to the Head never stay focused
never gets that's not you you're the
opposite yeah so you need you need to
tap into heart more and it'll make you a
more successful
business person human how husband you
don't like to focus on that how do you
tap into the heart is like I guess the
last question when you feel
something come through you
when you get an idea
your next step is when you get an idea
go do something on it
yeah
two percent rule two percent difference
right so when you get an idea what you
will do is automatically start to plan
it and judge it and come up with Evan's
holding up the special Cleveland Edition
uh Karen I got that copy as well 2019
tour let's go yeah that's it like when
you get an idea do something on it and
and the good news is it's all low risk
like what what's your next idea but to
to train yourself that great ideas flow
through you and to take some immediate
action on it this is what I did because
I'm much more logical and strategic
I I was like you and I had to train
myself to do more heart
first
big decisions with your heart because if
you go into your next career or your
next relationship just doing logic first
you're always going to be unhappy
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free we're worksheet just for
this video the worksheet will highlight
all the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be curious
being good with people has has
historically been a challenge for me
being shy introverted
um
find it find it hard to start off
conversations but the thing that
actually helped the most
um was actually just be curious about
people
just find a way to be curious about
somebody because I think especially if
you're introvert
uh we don't like having very surface
level conversations
we don't like talking about the weather
we don't like talking but hey how about
that sports team you know it feels fake
and introverts don't like being fake
uh but we love we actually love deep
conversations and so the way to do that
is to start finding one thing that you
can be really curious about the person
if you can generally be curious about
them then it's so much easier to have a
conversation and you're asking questions
about them and people love talking about
themselves so the way to be good with
somebody is just ask some questions but
not that it's leading to a sales pitch
or something that you just genuinely
care about the person and all of a
sudden they're doing most of the talking
and then at the end of it they're saying
wow that person you're such a great
conversationalist I really like talking
with you really was them doing most of
the talking and you asking the questions
but it's got to be questions that you
genuinely are curious about and care
about I find that that really helps me
rule number six is stay consistent focus
on who you are serving instead of who
you're not that one sentence is at the
core of how I've been able to stay so
consistent to keep making content to not
give up to not get too discouraged and
to get back up every single time and
keep going because I focus on who I am
serving instead of who I'm not
I just recently spoke at Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit and I
shared my graphic of how I've grown over
the years on my channel every time I
show that graph they always ask me how
did you keep going in in the first five
years when you had no subscribers when
you had no comments how did you keep
going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and I don't think I'm
superhuman I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story I had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles in getting my channel and just
belief in myself to put anything out
there I hated my first 350 videos I
couldn't watch anything back totally
embarrassed by everything I made
uh and it was 750 videos before I
inspired myself before I finally liked
one of my own videos like you know what
I'm starting to get decent at this that
was a good video 750 videos in before I
did that so how how do you keep going
how does that make any sense
because I always focus on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your girl think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you get
nothing right there's no reaction
there's no comments and then maybe you
get one comment and then maybe you get
five comments or maybe you get 10 likes
or maybe you get however many views on
your videos right you got 100 views on
your video now that's kind of the
standard now if you get 20 views again
on video oh that that doesn't feel so
good right or if you get a thousand
views on a video or ten thousand views
on if there are a hundred thousand views
in a video I remember the first time I
got a hundred thousand views on a video
it's like wow I've made it
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got ten percent of that and
you feel like oh I I suck it's not
working
right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people rule number
seven is help others I'm passionate
about helping I want people to learn man
and I don't think we're getting it in
schools I don't think you're getting
entrepreneurship knowledge and textbooks
and I'm passionate trying to help the
entrepreneurs who have the information
to get it out there so I've connected
with pretty much everybody I guess in
the thought leadership Entrepreneur
Space and I just help them with their
channels and and good stuff happens you
know I mean even looking at this I don't
know how we got initially connected but
we hopped on a call maybe a month or two
ago the look at your YouTube channel and
then you said hey man come on my show
like I'm down you know good things
happen when you give so if you're a
business owner you're an expert at
something your job is to teach people to
think like you think
and what I love you look at my ladder
you look at yourself you guys think
differently right the way you approach
things you're not your typical
boardroom CEO professional corporate guy
right and so
the questions that you ask are not the
normal ones the way you see the world is
not what other people see and so that's
that's your job as a as an expert as a
business leader to share the way that
you see the world so others can see the
world the same way rule number eight is
find your Niche today we are talking
about finding sponsors a couple ideas
here the first one is be the authority
in your industry and this is how I
started getting my first sponsors is
that people knew me as being the
entrepreneur guy first off just in my
city like I'm the entrepreneur guy in
Toronto and for this to happen it has to
be really Niche how do I Niche down so
that people find me because if you're
just talking about motivation you're up
against Tony Robbins and Mel Robbins and
Eric Thomas and Evan Carmichael and all
these big channels so why would a giant
company want to work with you at least
why would they come to you they wouldn't
be your first choice to come to you so I
was thinking about how can I be the
go-to in my specific industry and one of
the biggest things that I found too for
helping people get more business from
YouTube is going more Niche like who
specifically do you help and making
content directly geared towards them
this is something that you and I have
been working on and helping some of his
clients he's helped some clients get
five six figure deals from their YouTube
channels and they have 100 subscribers
what
yeah because the videos are specific
right so who do you ideally want to be
helping and making content directly
towards them and so a lot of a lot of
times the problem is our content is too
General it's too broad
yeah and you're going up against big
people and so you won't be the one that
they find but some of the stuff that
that he puts up is is relatively obscure
a niche like how can a dentist uh invest
in life insurance
a pretty specific Niche thing
and the goal isn't to have a million
views on that video but anybody who's
watching that video is going to be an
ideal target market for you
and so if if I'm a dentist and I'm
trying to invest in life insurance and I
find that video there aren't probably
too many videos there's videos talking
about how dentists can grow a business
or entrepreneurs and grow business this
video is talking about life insurance
but not that combination and in that
combination we start to get people
who are our ideal clients
so it's yes building up
I love that you're building a giant
channels what I love doing but I also
want you to to make money along the way
and if you have any kind of client
service business or products that you
want to sell making it specific knowing
that we're not trying to get a million
subscribers yet on these videos but it
can start to pay us it also attracts the
attention of potential sponsors
so the the more Niche you can get
especially when the Channel's small the
more Niche you can get the more people
will find you who care about that Niche
rule number nine is get excited about
the future how to get over someone that
you love after breakup when it still
hurts so whether it's a breakup in uh in
a personal relationship in a business
relationship you can always think about
what you what you would have done what
you should have done what you could have
done looking backwards but it very
rarely serves you the easiest way to
move past is to start to get excited
about the future
when you are excited about your future
you spend zero time thinking about all
the things that you did wrong going
backwards right you did the best you
could with what you had forgive yourself
if you had to do it all over again you
would probably play a little bit
different now because you're smarter
you're wiser you have more experience
but you can't go back in time and and
sitting wishing that you could and all
the mistakes that you would have fixed
doesn't serve you so the key is to start
getting excited about the future
get excited about the future what are
you building what are you creating what
are you moving towards not where you
have come from and where you struggled
and sucked so if it's a business
opportunity get excited about the new
business you're going to make if it's a
relationship
get excited about the next relationship
you're going to have right get on the
get on the different dating apps and see
who's out there see who's on the market
for you right now and get excited like
allow yourself to dream again and to
wish again and to Hope again because
that thing that you came from was not
the one for you anyway you're trying to
move through some past mistakes
you give yourself credit for doing the
best you could with what you had and
then we start getting excited about the
future that is still ahead item number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is dream big our ideas are
endless you know you've got big ideas
as you want to change the world right
and that's great and it's great like
dream dream big and okay
it's it's then this gets so easy to get
lost in our Big Dreams and it's like
well what do I what do I do we're
building the ladder we're creating the
bridge we're getting in the boat and
we're rolling like this is the first
step and and what's great is you already
have a product service that you can sell
so something like I don't know what I'm
gonna sell I don't know who I can help I
don't know what my skills are like
you've already figured that out which is
great
so now we just need to figure out okay
uh how many clients you need to need to
get so that you're going to get that
team those two people and then you'll
feel so you'll have so much more
momentum like just imagine an EA or a VA
taking 20 30 hours a week of work off
your plate what does that free up for
you to do
yeah
right a lot like maybe maybe you can
already afford to hire that person now
and if it's not 20 hours a week maybe
it's five hours a week or 10 hours a
week right
um yes yes that's how you get the scale
up yeah but it's these steps
local that's it that's good yeah
because a lot of people hear that
message but I don't want to I don't want
to dream so small
no I'm not asking to dream small like
dream big dream bigger
we're just building the plan to actually
get there because the thing that's
missing between where and not just you
where like most people are and where
they want to be is they don't have the
team and the resources to do it so let's
go get you some more resources so you
can get the team to go off and build
your even bigger mission
get rid of your 10-year goals and create
a mission instead
I think a lot of people are so worried
about where they're going to be in a
year and five years and 10 years we do
these goals planning actually you ever
gone through that you ever gone through
a goal planning exercise goal set and
exercise at events you read a book says
where you're going to be in a year and
five years or 10 years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercise is the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
is plan a life for who you are right now
it's like there's no way there's no way
not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world evolves the new technology comes
out and New Opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head it might flip a lot
of what you've been told or taught or
thought on its head and listen if having
that 10-year goal works for you and is
actually motivating cool keep keep with
it keep going if it's helping you use it
but if you feel like there's something
more or you feel like 10 year goal is
not enough you don't feel motivated when
you look at your 10-year goal from two
years ago it doesn't appeal to you
anymore it's probably why you know
you're you're growing too quickly the
problem is not your goals the problems
that you grew too much the 10-year goal
was great for who you were three years
ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turning to the next generation
of you
and So my answer is admission what's the
mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
has happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so I was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here
there's no way just with the with the
impact I've had with the people I've met
with the even just the confidence to sit
here guys I would have been so terrified
to sit in a park making a video
terrified of who's watching me who's
judging me who's coming around the
corner who's behind there maybe you know
looking at me and judging me you know
they've been it's would have been
impossible so the person I was 10 years
ago would have never even thought of
this as a possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you come with a mission it's a
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the market and
Technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the mission well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that
this video in some way is a video that
moves a needle just a little bit for
somebody watching maybe it's you maybe
this is the video that you decide I'm
gonna I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
find my mission I'm gonna stop creating
10-year goals and stop over planning
over preparing and overthinking and over
strategizing and over doubting myself
and just go do something like maybe
today this is the video or maybe I make
another video today that accomplishes
that like that's that's my goal that's
why I do what I do that's what gives me
the energy to wake up when
every bone in my body saying you know
sleep
don't do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you can think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go your by
no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck
in your story your message your content
you reaching out you could make the
difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you want to grow is
the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it it's never
too late to get started it's never too
late to say yes it's never too late to
start to chase down your dreams the
thing that you got inside you it's never
too late we create these stories for
ourselves as I am too old to get started
I am to acts like fill in a blank of
whatever excuse you've got for not
taking action
[Music]
it's just a story
you're just afraid and the only thing
you're missing is momentum
it's never too late
I remember when I started my business I
thought I was too young you know
I was 19 years old I was selling the
people who
were experts in science and I sucked at
science and they were two to three times
my age and I had phds and I thought I
was too young they'd never take me
seriously and that was one of the things
that really held back the growth of my
business was
just my limiting belief that I was too
young
and I talk to people all the time and
you have people who say they're too
young
and then instantly they become too old
like but when you have the right age you
know you're too young to do it then
you're too old to do it when were you
actually ever the right age when have
you ever said you know what I'm the
right age to do this thing
right we never we never do that it's
always just the fear talking
and so you have to step up you have to
step out you have to say yes
and you have to get started people ask
me all the time is it too late to get
started on YouTube I was at a conference
I was speaking at this weekend and
is it too late Evan is it too did I miss
the boat
are you kidding me
first off YouTube is growing like crazy
second the the education on YouTube is
still pretty low there's so many people
going and there's still so few people
who are creating good quality education
look at whatever field you're in is
probably even less
and third even if YouTube does go away
at some point
there's gonna be something else
people's attention is not going offline
anytime soon it's only going to increase
if YouTube goes away something else will
will come up and your ability to speak a
message to a camera is a skill set that
will serve you for life of course it's
not too late it's just your fear talking
go up Big Dreams and big goals and big
Ambitions are possible
there's so few worlds where it actually
is too late right and like if you're 70
years old and you want to play you know
in the NBA Athletics is the easy one to
go to then that's it's too late you know
you're not going to go you're not going
to be a professional NBA player sorry
but could you be involved in the world
of could you start a great podcaster on
it a YouTube channel around it or be an
agent or like infinite number of things
in that world of course and chances are
most of your goals dreams things that
you want to do
are not tied to anything physical where
there's going to be a significant
decline right like what are the things
what do you want to do what are your
goals it's people who have done it at a
much older age than you
so how do we unlock it how do we start
to make
that momentum actually happen in your
life step number one
get really clear on what you want
what do you want what are your goals
what do you what do you want to do
what's the voice inside your head that
is telling you I wish I could do this
thing I really want to do this right
like getting really clear because
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs and you
know that you're capable of more and you
know you want to have a bigger impact
and you know that
that you don't want to stay stuck here
but you don't know what the thing looks
like you know it's not as clear of what
you want to do you just know that you're
stuck and you're capable of more
well you definitely don't have the whole
thing planned out but what's the next
step
just getting clear on what you want the
next step to be
can make a big big big big big big big
difference
because it gives you some clarity
whether it's even the perfect I mean
it's not going to be the perfect step
don't worry about being a perfect step
it probably won't be the right the right
step it's a step
and in taking a step you learn a lot and
you make a lot of mistakes you make a
ton of mistakes and you figure things
out I remember when I first got my phone
I was recording and I I did this video
and I was I was so proud of the video
and then I realized I captured the whole
thing in slow motion mode
it's like the audio was terrible you
can't use it I couldn't use it like oh
it was so good what come on slow motion
mode you just you're gonna make mistakes
at the beginning that's okay but what's
the next step getting some clarity over
what that next step should be is really
important part two is then go get some
Heroes
it could be a mentor who you can
actually talk to and learn from but
Heroes
and when I say Heroes I mean people
who've done the thing that you want to
do
whenever I feel less than whenever I
feel like I can't do it whenever I feel
not good enough I Look to people who
have done it
and I realize that they have done it
with less resources less money less time
less
skills and what I have right now Your
Heroes the people who you love look up
to respect the most they did it they
accomplished with less than what you
have right now
and if they can do it you can do it too
and the whole point of that is a push to
start taking action it's not to say oh
well I suck I can never be Oprah Winfrey
or whoever go look at Oprah's story and
see where she came from and see how how
poor she was and see what her upbringing
was and imagine being Oprah imagine
having a terrible upbringing uh you know
being raped early on having tons of
violence in the family bouncing from
home to home
being so poor that she couldn't afford
clothes and her grandmother would so a
dress for her out of a potato bag like
imagine you're going to school in a
potato bag
that your grandmother sewed together
because you didn't have enough money to
actually get real close
can you imagine
how bad is your life compared to that
how bad was your upbringing compared to
that
right to go from where she started to
where she's at
what's your excuse
and again it's not meant to be a
negative like oh you're right I'm so
hard on myself I suck no it's more like
well that's what's possible
as soon as you get over the store you're
telling yourself that's what's possible
if she could do it
from that upbringing why can't you why
can't I
and anytime I feel like I can't do it
that that's what I default back to it's
like look at your Heroes look at where
they started look at where they came
from and chances are Your Heroes already
started with less than what you already
have right now and so surrounding
yourself with them
can give you the hope and the feeling
like it is possible if you feel like
you're too old for something then
surround yourself with entrepreneurs who
started who are way older than you
look at people who have started and they
started I don't know how old you are you
know people say at I'm 24 years old is
it too late to get started
but on every age people feel it's too
late
so surround yourself with the stories of
people who started when they're older it
gives you the inspiration to go to make
to create
and then number three is come back to
service think about service think about
who you're doing this for this is this
is bigger than you it's not just about
you
so who are you going to help
whenever it's just about you whenever
it's you're doing something for just
selfish reasons
you'll never put in the same amount of
work as if you feel like you're
responsible to somebody else this is
where a lot of entrepreneurs struggle in
starting their own business because when
you had a job you had a boss and your
boss would tell you what to do if you
didn't show up to a meeting you'd be in
trouble you know so you'd show up for
other people but you don't show up for
yourself
we just won't show up for ourselves as
much people show up for other people so
the way to hack it is to feel like what
you're doing is actually serving other
people
and if you're an entrepreneur land you
can think about the customers you're
going to serve the people who will
consume your content or buy your
products or service in the life changing
impact that you're going to have and
feel it and connect to that if you don't
have a business yet or that's not your
ambition just think about your message
to your kids
think about the message to your family
think about the message to the people
around you is your message to your kids
current or future
you know what it's too late
you when you get an idea just tell
yourself that you can't do it
you know is that going to be your
message to your kid of course not
but it's your message to yourself
and the people closest to you will model
much more what you do
your actions your beliefs more than what
you say
you could tell them believe in yourself
you're not it's not too late go ahead go
do it you can make this happen but when
they see you sitting on the sidelines
telling yourself that you're too old and
you can't do it that's the behavior
they're going to model
so if you're not going to do it for
yourself
that's not enough of an oomph to get you
out of the bed and actually creating
your thing then think about who you're
serving today
think about the people you're going to
help
people who by you showing up is going to
have an impact on their lives
it's not too late to start
it's never too late to start
your life
could be so different
if you woke up and started doing the
thing that was in your heart it's not
going to work out at the beginning
you're going to have a lot of failures
you're going to have a lot of laughs
you're going to have a lot of struggles
as you get going
but holy cow your life can be
dramatically different one year two
years five years from today
if you just decided you know what
I'm just tired of staying stuck
I'm tired of coming up with excuses
I'm tired of playing small
time
I need this for myself
I need this for my family
I need this for the people who I'm going
to serve and help
it's time
it's your time
let's see what you can make I think you
should have a hard time explaining what
you do
like I think I think if you I think if
you don't have a hard time explaining
what you do then you hate your life like
then you you you're living inside an
easy to Define box and you're not happy
there and and not a masculine feminine
thing that's just a human thing like so
you should have a hard time it's good
it's good if you have a hard time
explaining what you do means you're
expressing yourself and you're creating
a unique life right which is the goal
for all of us
um in terms of you know energy I think I
think how I approach it is less of like
a shield you know and trying to fight it
and hold it back and like you can't come
in and more of a dance and and some
dance Partners you dance with and go a
long way and some you you drop off and
move on right and so I'm less concerned
about the doing as much as you know why
I'm here I don't know what we're talking
about there's no like preset list of
questions like Eric you have to talk
about this or I'm not coming on you know
like I don't know what we're going to
talk about and I'm dancing with the with
what where you're throwing out it's like
you're you're paying chin and I'm
catching and I'm throwing the ball back
to you and this is our dance in every
dance is unique and different and you
get a chance to express yourself a
little bit differently and sometimes
that dance last five minutes or may last
a lifetime and so I just see myself kind
of that's how I navigate through it is
if you're always kind of resisting and
fighting you're always stressed out and
full of anxiety and and always in
protection mode and that when you're
deep in protection mode you're not
you're not in the creative space ready
to make something amazing and abundant
right and so it's like okay I'm gonna
that doesn't work for me I'm I'm moving
on to the next stance and she's kind of
dancing through the energy and the more
you can actually feel it the first step
is awareness it's great that you even
caught it because you're feeling like
stressed out and overwhelmed but it's
like you don't know why okay well now we
get a sense of why but now you get to
choose a different dance partner
and that's how I see it and we're just
dancing down down the path the people
you're surrounded by matters your
environment right now the people you
hang out with
it's all been perfectly designed to keep
you stuck to keep you small to keep you
where you are to keep your growth curve
slow
you know we have these negative voices
in our heads but
somebody put those voices in your head
you telling yourself that you suck and
you can't do it that's that's not your
voice you know when you're when you're
born
everything is possible think about even
when you were a kid your dreams your
goals what you wanted to be what you
wanted to do I remember I wanted to be a
baseball player in the summer and then
via fireman or a police officer in the
winter in the off season
and
think about what happens to those dreams
now some of them might have been to to
uh We've outgrown them you know why I
want to be a police officer here because
I saw a police officer on the street or
something but some of them we outgrow
but a lot of times we just also not just
outgrow the idea of it but it gets
knocked out of us you know that sense of
hope and potential and what we can do
and where we can go and what we can
learn and who we can be they get it gets
knocked out of us
by our parents by our teachers or the
people around us by Society by school it
gets knocked out of us
and that is not good
you know it sucks
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you stuck
to keep you safe and to keep you small
but that is not your voice
that is not your voice and so part of
the work is finding your voice and being
willing to go down the path that nobody
else is going down one of the reasons
why entrepreneurship is so hard is that
people are
feel that they're stuck have you felt
stuck have you felt like you're the only
one who's doing what you're doing do you
feel like nobody understands you nobody
gets you nobody supports you nobody
nobody's here to tell you what what you
can do in a loving way forward
nobody is as optimistic or as hopeful or
as ambitious as you
and it's not that those people don't
exist it's just not in your environment
and
it's easy to stay being that
big fish in the small pond you know it's
easy to say stuck being the person who's
constantly pouring and loving and caring
and giving in to others but at what
point do you decide that you need more
for yourself as well
because when you can be around people
who are doing bigger things that push
you that make you see things are
possible in a whole new way it just
changes everything
when I got started as an entrepreneur
I had I had business partners so that
was really helpful
but apart from that I I isolated myself
I didn't see my friends I had no money I
was embarrassed I was ashamed I was
alone
which made it really difficult for me to
wake up every day and go do the thing
that I wanted to do and and just took
its toll on my self-worth and
self-esteem you know that this isn't
working I've poured so much energy and
love and heart into and it's just not
working out
and one of the things that helped was
getting a mentor
and
over the years I've had a bunch of
mentors who've helped me with different
things and I'm I've realized in that
process that I'm not a dummy
that I'm not stupid
and that when I have somebody to guide
me and help me when I'm around other
people
who are going through similar things it
helps Lift Me Up
and you'll have moments where you'll
have people who are way ahead of you
but it's not only the people who are way
ahead of you
around people who are
people who are ambitious and going after
their dream just being around those
people starts to change things so let me
share two examples
one
if we're looking at pointing up
learning for some reason a lot more than
us
I recently came back from Phoenix
Arizona I was speaking at a couple
events in one of the groups you had to
pay a hundred thousand dollars to be in
it's a pretty high level group
pretty impressive people and on the last
day I had breakfast coffee with one of
the members at his home and calling it a
home is an understatement it's a it's
like four homes in one home it's a
compound and
this guy had just sold his business for
over 200 million dollars in hanging with
him and seeing how he reacted to things
and getting some feedback on my business
I I came away not just with ideas on
what to do but just inspiration and
motivation and excitement and energy is
like wow
this guy's just playing at a whole other
level
and coming home it's like I'm on the
airplane I'm on fire you know let's
let's get to work let's start building
the Empire let's start having a bigger
impact and reaching even more people
but it's not every day that you can kind
of go hang out with people who sold the
business for 200 million dollars right
like oh that's easy for you you know you
met that person what am I supposed to do
so you find peers
you find communities
who find clubs
that's why I created movement makers
which is awesome and every two weeks we
meet and connect and
I'm helping
thought leaders for on the way up build
their content build their movement get
their message out to the world
and the biggest part of it is I think
not being able to learn from me and hang
out but being able to be with other
people who are doing something similar
that we do challenges where people are
making content together and going live
together and the amount of times people
have come in have never gone live or
afraid to make their first video and
then somebody says hey I'll help do it
with you
let's go live together
it makes such a difference
who's doing that for you who's taking
your ideas and saying hey let's go do
that together I'll help you
and so joining some kind of community
and they don't have to be people who are
way far ahead of you
you know you may not be connecting with
a 200 million dollar entrepreneur but
just people who are on the same path who
who are lifting others up who are
pouring into you who are ambitious as
well just just being around them makes a
huge difference
a guy an entrepreneur invested into
Alex has been
struggling with not having entrepreneur
friends and connections and being the
the you know lonely entrepreneurs I said
just go go join some entrepreneur events
go to some entrepreneur meetups and go
to conferences that are happening in the
city and he just recently went to one I
said listen your goal here is not to not
to learn from the speakers
you won't be impressed by the speakers
you'll you'll you already know most of
the content your goal is for the energy
and connection your goal should be to
talk to 25 people
each day there's two days so go talk to
50 people and then out of that to be
able to have a connection with with a
couple people that you want to follow up
with
and so you know tomorrow he's going
downtown to meet one of the
entrepreneurs that he met at the event
that's much more powerful than learning
because he knows all the content he
consumes my content he watches the
videos he's he's a learner
the point of going there is not to learn
from the speakers the point is to go and
meet and connect with other people
and so join some kind of community for
whatever the thing is that you're trying
to do so that you you're willing to walk
alone but hopefully you don't have to
and then last but not least I'd suggest
just consuming content
that's what really helped me it still
helps me if I'm learning from Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever it is
feature their videos
sometimes if I wake up and the energy is
not there I'll go for a morning walk
which always helps and then I'll feed my
mind with
with the video
from something on my own channel I still
make the videos for me because I want
them and I need them every day as a
reminder
to think bigger to play a bigger game
that what I'm doing is possible that it
can't happen that others have proved it
and that I just need to believe more
it is scary and hard to run your own
race
and a lot of people will doubt you along
the way and tell you that it's not
possible even if it's in a loving way
it's not possible that you can't do it
and we often then lead to doubt in
ourselves
and that voice comes in and says that we
can't do it
and so the answer is to start to shift
the environment
to start to eliminate the people who are
creating those negative thoughts around
this to start to try to get some mentors
to help teach and learn to try to join a
community of people who are just as
ambitious as we are trying to accomplish
great things and to be around the
content of people who Inspire us to want
to go off and be amazing
can't do that
your environment's been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are but
you don't have to stay stuck where you
are
Where You Are
at the end of the life it doesn't have
to be where you are right now difference
is going to be how much are you changing
up the environment and the people you're
hanging out with this is like the only
thing I had going for me you know like I
wasn't I wasn't super smart I wasn't
charismatic I was not getting any you
know real success like 2 000 subscribers
five years in
um the only thing I had going for me is
I always focused on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't yeah
so for me it's like if I had 50 people
watch the videos like 150 people
watching a video that's pretty cool
right like those are 50 real people who
saw that like if you wouldn't go give a
a speech at a library or something and
50 people showed up at least for me at
the beginning I'd be super nervous and
excited to go up and do that but when
it's online we feel like we're some kind
of failure and I'm ambitious and I want
to grow and I want to have a huge impact
and it's great to chase numbers
um but I just always focus on who I was
actually helping I think that leads to a
lot more satisfaction doesn't lead to
doesn't mean you stay complacent and and
only like gratitude doesn't mean that
you have to stay stuck but it it makes
you feel more connected to impact you
know like we all want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter that
we're going to do something today maybe
we're going to make something that hits
a million people or maybe we do
something that just touches one person's
life but we want to feel like today is
going to matter in some way and that's
what I always just if I saw 50 views on
videos like this is weird
stop trying to do this alone
if you've got a big idea inside you you
can't do this alone you need people
around you to help you to encourage you
to support you to cover your weaknesses
to help you actually go off and
accomplish that big dream of yours this
is one of the biggest things that I
think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs back
is you're probably decently good at the
thing that you want to do
you know you've had some experience or
you've gone and learned and figured it
out and you still to get better as you
keep practicing and keep going and doing
more and maybe at some point you even
did try to hire somebody maybe at some
point you did try to bring somebody on
and it didn't work out
didn't work out
and here's where everybody makes the
mistake you Retreat and go back to say
you know what it was just a lot faster
when I did it myself does that happen
has that happened to you ever been there
you hired somebody you thought I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out
and then you go back to say I'm just
going to do this all myself no no no no
no no no that is not the answer
that is not the answer that's like if
you go on one date and it doesn't work
out now you're never gonna go on another
date again you're never gonna be married
right that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense you're living in
fear as opposed to actually trying to
build the thing that you're capable of
building
here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you don't
know what you're doing
right it's like when you first did
anything you don't know what you're
doing
so why do you expect to be great at
picking the right person and then
treating them well then managing them
well you don't know what you're doing uh
there's a guy in my movement makers who
joined my Discord as well
and he was talking about how he had I
hired his second video editor and it
didn't work out and he had to let the
person go so he's hired two video
editors both of them couldn't get his
style
and he had to let them go and he's going
back to editing everything himself now
as a short-term solution great like
stuff has to get up videos have to be
edited get them out
but don't stop searching
just because you had two failed hires
right like if you
tomorrow are editing videos awesome but
if you next year are still editing your
videos not awesome nope not awesome not
anymore right this is how we start to
raise our standards
and so the first two people that you
hired weren't good fits great keep
searching keep looking
your perfect fit is out there and as you
go through some people
and go through the process you'll get
better at actually finding the right
person
you know you'll get better at it don't
judge yourself to say well I suck at
this I can't higher I'm never going to
find the person it's just faster to do
it myself right there's that old
expression you can go fast by yourself
but you go far with the team
you have to build a team
so let's talk about how to do it okay
let's stop let's talk about steps
practical steps building the team
creating the culture someone who now has
37 people on the team I'm not I'm not
Jeff Bezos with uh I don't know how many
thousands of people are on his team but
37 on our team right now how do you how
do you go from starting up to that step
number one
is figure out what is the most important
skill
that you need that has to get done in
the business that you suck at
okay and you don't want to get better at
what do you suck at that has to get done
in the business not something that you
know maybe it's a nice to have but like
it has to get done in the business you
suck at it and not just you suck at it
right now you just you never want to get
better at it you're just not interested
in it some people love this thing and
you hate it and you never want to get
better at it what is that thing
that's the first person you need to
bring on into your business it could be
part-time it it I it definitely should
not be a full-time person
here's why
one you don't know how to hire yet
two it's going to take you too long to
be able to save up the money to hire
somebody full-time and three you're not
used to managing people
so you want a part-time person when I
first started I had interns I had
interns from high school who were
helping me do a lot of the things that I
need to get done and it was part of
their school credit Nina is back
um I did foreign language interns and
people came to Toronto as part of their
education
being from a different country learning
English and getting job experience
when you find people I've had people
volunteer to join I've had people work
one hour a day to join right just like
you need to start getting some people
involved because
it makes you feel like you're not alone
doing this which is a big deal and it
also starts building some traction you
know starts finally getting some of the
things off your plate that you wish
didn't exist anymore and suddenly now
they don't because someone else is
taking care of it right
step number two is you have to start
asking for help this is a big problem
for a lot of entrepreneurs you're afraid
to ask for help at the startup phase
especially
like well so what if they steal my idea
it's one of the most common questions we
ever felt that what if what if I tell
somebody my idea and they steal it they
go with it
well
it's possible
it's possible very low possibility most
people are are running their own
business the amount of people have come
to me and say Evan uh I'd love your help
on this but but I need you to sign this
NDA non-disclosure agreement it's like I
don't care about your idea I have my own
business to run I've got my own channels
my own team my own things to worry about
I'm not gonna they think the top
priority is you have some great idea
that I'm going to then take and run with
that that's now my new business plan no
and now you miss the chance to actually
get some feedback and help
so you have to share your ID the idea
alone is not enough it's the execution
it really matters
so it's not just the idea that you've
got it's can you be the one to go off
and create it to make it to to birth it
to turn it into reality and speed
matters
have you ever seen anybody with your
idea right air quotes your idea
go off and win while you were still
sitting on the sidelines
right that seen it happen so many times
have so many people message me about it
it's like I had this idea three years
ago and I didn't do it and now here's
this person off making millions off of
it well what's the difference chances
are they had less heart than you less
less
of a drive to do good less caring than
you so why are they winning well because
they started and they asked for help
and you were trying to do it all by
yourself
so you have to share your idea you have
to recruit people on board you have to
ask for help because those people can
make the difference between you actually
following through on your goals
I then step three is you have to Mentor
the people on your team you have to care
about them as humans the next big
mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make when
they're when they're hiring is okay this
person's gonna come on they're going to
take all the stuff off my plate so I can
focus on being the CEO and then
everything's gonna be great
and that's a nice Theory
um you know that that kind of happens
but what you want to think about is
this is a human working with you
you know this is a human who's got goals
and their own Ambitions and their own
dreams and your job should be to help
them grow as a human that they should be
better
as a person by spending time with you by
being around you
and by being in your company
most people treat people like robots
they treat them like monkeys okay get
this done get that done perfect gone you
know you made you made my life easier
awesome that's what you're hired to do
go do your job
where where
people make the mistake of is one not
giving enough training at the beginning
like did you actually set somebody up
for success and the two just not caring
about them enough as a human
I'm actually starting to find it harder
as I grow it was a lot easier when I had
one to five people on the team but at 37
I don't know what everybody's up to I
don't remember everybody's projects I'm
not in as much of the day-to-day of what
they're doing I find it hard to balance
everybody's
goals and just stay on top of of their
life and I don't know what it's going to
look like when we're at 50 people or 75
people or 100 people I don't know what
that process looks like I'm figuring out
you know what I gotta ask for help as I
grow
but two of the things that I've done
that have worked out pretty well
the first is
I dedicate Mondays to team days
so I have an entire day
of the week that's dedicated to team
and so
I'm spending that day on Zoom calls or
in person meeting with Team asking them
what's going on helping them with their
projects and just spending time with
them and so people know that on Mondays
when they save all their stuff and talk
to me about it
scheduling in time for Team matters so I
have different things for different days
of the week today's a Tuesday because
I'm recording so recording is Tuesday
but yesterday was Monday and and I was
spending the whole time basically on
Zoom calls with team
the second thing that I'll do is a is a
quarterly check-in with people and we
don't even talk about the business
you should do it on a Sunday so it's not
a work day it's a Sunday morning coffee
every Sunday I'm spending with someone
on my team
so Sunday morning I grab my coffee they
grab whatever drink they want and we do
a session together and we will touch on
business we'll touch on what they're
doing but not operationally focused not
hey you didn't get this thing done or
hey how are we doing on this project
it's more like where do you want to go
with your life
what do you curious about what are you
loving about the work that you're doing
here how can I help you get to the next
step what else are you curious about
what are your other goals just just a
life conversation
and you'd be surprised that
what comes out
and most people all they all they really
need is just somebody to listen to them
and care
and sometimes action happens immediately
after sometimes it happens you know the
next month or the next quarter but when
you know the hopes the goals the dreams
the Ambitions of the people on your team
the people around you it allows you to
be a much better and much more effective
leader
so we took you to this the process of
startup zero you know Team all the way
to now how do you manage you know your
first 37 at least people in your company
but underpinning all of this is
the understanding that you can't do this
alone I feel sometimes like okay one one
piece of the puzzle is for example going
and it's kind of slowing down and I'm
I'm feeling a little bit exhausted so I
want to like turn and pivot into
something that also excites me and it's
a different kind of hobby different
interest different excitement right so
it's like one thing I'll be talking
about you know leadership development or
the other and then all of a sudden I'll
I'll be curious about fashion and want
to like navigate those two polarities so
that I'm constantly feeling like I'm
adding value in different Industries
well here's the thing I would I would um
encourage a perspective shift for you to
see that those are not actual polarities
okay so inside but this is the challenge
we have so inside of leadership and
fashion
what actually connects them like what's
the core value that you have the
expression for me so then that's it but
yeah so so expression Eric is all about
expression yeah and and it's how do you
express yourself better and and how do
you allow others to express themselves
better like if somebody said Eric Mana I
listen to your show or watch you or I
had a conversation with you and you gave
me the permission to express myself
fully
that's like the greatest thing you could
hear from somebody I love it right yeah
so yeah to me this but it's the job
though for you then becomes to be able
to communicate expression through the
work so it's not if somebody just looked
at the content he's talking about
leadership over here he's talking about
fashion over here it feels like it's all
over the place
because you haven't done the job and I
mean I haven't seen all your cons so I'm
just you know putting that on but when
you can do the job to explain that it's
expression
then it all makes sense then I'm
watching Eric not just for leadership
tips I'm watching Eric to figure out how
can I express myself better in all areas
of my life there's this great interview
with Jay-Z where he was talking about
somebody asked him reporter asked him
like how do you how do you move from
from rapping to Fashion to being an
entrepreneur and it's like it's all it's
just all about I think expression might
have been is either expression or
creativity it was like it was it because
it is what stops us from chasing our
obsession is the Judgment that it's
wrong we feel that it's wrong to pour so
much time and energy and effort into
something especially if it's not working
out in pain dividends and results it's
yes the people around us telling us that
what are you doing that's crazy stop
doing it but it's also us it's our own
voice in our own head saying can I do
this am I wasting my time is this thing
even worth doing and then what ends up
happening is you regret not taking the
action right we don't regret the things
that we do off often It's usually the
things that we don't do the actions
untuck the goals that you had that you
are too afraid to do something on
and that Obsession that we felt was
wrong think of this in my life I used to
judge myself a lot on this and I would
get obsessed like one of the things that
I think now is a core strength of mine
as I get obsessed on something then it
has to happen I was at an event and uh
it was a YouTube event and it was a
really really big famous guy runs a
bunch of events pretty well known and I
was on him for you had to start a
YouTube channel did you got to start a
YouTube channel and I was just on him on
him on him on him fast forward today is
about three years ago he's got a YouTube
channel he's got six figures and
subscribers
um and he's on my mind because I was
texting him some thumbnail ideas this
morning and I just I was on him I
couldn't let it go like this has to
happen you you need to do this and it
just felt right and that energy and that
conviction is one of the things that
helped move the needle and you've got
ideas and energy and great things in you
and products you want to create and
services you want to launch and people
that you want to serve and help and it
and trust it and listen to it then the
the thing that's in your heart that is
this little it's a it's a it's a muscle
to develop the courage to follow the
obsession because
a lot of our brain takes over and tells
us to be safe and be practical and do
the smart thing and make sure that
you're paying your bills and all of that
and yes of course you have to learn how
to pay your bills
but where we taught the courage muscle
where we taught the obsession muscle
where we taught to to you've got this
dream that is noble and worthy where are
we taught to actually follow through on
and at least do something about it so
over the years it's taken me a long time
and and the goal with this video is to
try to help it
not take as long for you over the years
I used to judge myself for wanting
something
and just thinking about it constantly
and sometimes those ideas lead to
long-term projects look at my YouTube
channel how my main channel it's been 13
years
13 years
[Music]
oh you know 13 000 videos something like
that not all of them are public
how what because because I'm obsessed I
want to I want to bring more value I
want to create more content I want to
impact more entrepreneurs it's a how do
you how do you stay consistent on
something because I want to do it
because I'm obsessed about it because I
feel like it's going to matter even at
the beginning when I had 25 subscribers
in my first year and 7 000 subscribers
after five years like how do you keep
going well I was obsessed with trying to
make content that I thought would help
some people and that's been a long-term
Obsession there's something a lot
shorter term
um I remember I was on writing my book
your one word also built to serve both
of my books were flowing through me and
there was every reason why I shouldn't
do it your one word I finished writing
the book on my cruise I was on vacation
with my wife and we're enjoying our
vacation and it was flowing through it
was like I need to I need to do this and
so while she slept I I wrote my book and
while she uh went to a show or or did
some something at the spa I finished
writing the book we still did the
excursions and saw the cities together
but the second part of the cruise I was
I was just in it was flowing through me
I had to get this thing done otherwise I
know I'm going to regret it if I built
to serve I wrote it when I was on my
tour in 2019 and I did not have time to
write a book I did not have time I mean
I was behind that everything where we're
traveling every four days to New City
I'm presenting it just I did not have
time to do this
I did not have time and yet it was
flowing through me and like I'm obsessed
I have to get this done I have to have
to have to have to get this done
and
with experience and age and time I've
learned to lean in on those things
instead of Judge them where typically
what happens is you come with a great
idea you think it's great it has a lot
of potential and then you immediately
judge it to say well I can't do that I'm
not worthy I'm not good enough I don't
have the skills I don't have the money
uh why am I still spending all this time
on thinking about some idea that that I
could never do we instantly judge it and
maybe you do a little bit of work on it
you start trying and you taste and you
test and you explore a little bit and
then and then what happens if you don't
get immediate results you wake up the
next day or the next week or the next
month and say see I knew you couldn't do
it
you're crazy why would you think you
could do this and instantly we talk
ourselves down from it
and what I've learned to try to do and
I'm still
working on it is to listen to that
intuition and listen to that gut and and
it's right and it's Noble and great
ideas flow through you and stop judging
them and so the process I use
is one that great ideas flow through me
so just believe the great ideas flow
through you this is how you eliminate
the overthinking and and your brain
getting in the way you come with a great
idea your brain gets in the way how do
you get out of that great ideas flow
through you just trust a great idea
through the fact that it came to you as
long as you're in a positive optimistic
energy you know serving state if you're
feeling jealous or rage or you know if
somebody cuts you off in in line I'm in
my car right now we're parked but
if somebody cuts you off when you're
you're upset maybe maybe the idea that
comes to you is not a good idea but if
you're feeling positive and encouraged
and optimistic and and serving and want
to help and an idea comes to you trust a
great ideas flow through you just tell
yourself great it is flow through me and
that at least gives me the courage to
stop overthinking and start doing
something step number two is just get
started start I called the two percent
difference what's the first two percent
we waste our best energy on trying to
plan out 100 of where this company or
idea business is going to grow that's
not the way to do it you'll you'll never
plan it at 100 you have no idea what's
going to happen with this thing and so
instead of spending your best energy
this is the problem you spend your best
energy
like this we could do that oh yeah
here's how it could work out your energy
where you feel confident and bold you
spend your best energy on research and
planning instead of doing something and
research and planning are important but
it can't be the first step because
you're again wasting your best energy
you wake up the next day you feel like
oh I can't do this so instead your best
energy the first step needs to be the
first two percent you're doing something
you're calling somebody you're booking
something you're creating something when
I had an idea to start a podcast I I
messaged my friend Marcus said we're
going to start a podcast and he said
when tonight what do you mean when
tonight when I'm back from my tour in a
month and a half no we're starting it
tonight
but we don't have the gear what are we
going to talk about and we'll figure it
out I'm gonna get back to we're going to
drive to my Airbnb and we're gonna we're
gonna launch our podcast together
tonight it has to happen tonight or it's
not going to happen
right that that becomes a process super
important and step number three is just
expect to suck at the start expect to
suck at the start we expect to be great
for whatever reason at the beginning of
when we're doing our thing right we
expect to be great don't expect to be
great expect to suck expect the first
thing to be terrible for it not to work
out
cheers it's not gonna work out not as
you plan not at the beginning you don't
get on a bike and just ride it you don't
make a video and just crush it right it
doesn't mean that you suck as a person
you just don't have the skill set yet
and by practicing and trying and tasting
and testing you'll get a little bit
better and when you start something and
you expect to be great and then you're
not great you quit
but when you start something and you
expect it to be terrible then anything
above terrible is progress his momentum
is a win and celebrate that celebrate
the fact that you took a step celebrate
the fact that you recorded a video
celebrate the fact that you wrote the
first page in your book celebrate the
fact that you you launched your first
episode of a podcast even though you
don't know what questions to talk about
what questions to ask the formatting all
of that stuff that doesn't matter you
started momentum you celebrate the
momentum and expect the results to suck
at the beginning and if you keep going
you'll learn the skill to get better at
the thing so it's okay to be obsessed
it's okay there's there's a great idea
inside you that you know you want to
work on that you know you need to do
be obsessed on it start small create
something right now apply the two
percent difference trust the great ideas
flow through you expect to expect a suck
at the beginning
and make it because otherwise you look
back on your life at this moment and say
I could have done something back then
and I wish I had the starting point to
find your passion is to say yes more
we are in the no business new idea comes
oh no I can't do that new opportunity
arises you get invited no no someone
like me can't do this we're constantly
saying no no no no no no no no no no no
you'll never find your passion by saying
no it's actually the opposite you got to
say yes you got to say yes to
Opportunities you got to say yes to
ideas you got to say yes to that thing
that comes into your head that maybe you
can go off and do yes I'm gonna try I'm
going to be willing to suck I'm going to
be willing for it not to work out but
I'm going to try because we judge things
before we've been trying I like to say
how do you know what your favorite food
is well you know by by trying you know
by tasting a whole bunch of different
foods until you find the one that you
love like wow that's my favorite food
work most people they don't try enough
Foods if you think about sushi
did I use as an example I uh wrote off
sushi at the beginning like that sounds
nasty I mean like not judging you want
to eat it awesome but it sounds gross
it's raw fish
wrapped in seaweed with some rice and
fish eggs that sounds gross right for
someone who's not used to it
Italian you know Western diet that
sounds gross
and you're going to dip it in soy sauce
and hot mustard right but you know what
I'm just gonna try it you know what this
is really good
it tastes so good all right now I love
sushi so she's Sushi's got to be in my
top five favorite foods but we judge
things and we're doing that nachos with
Foods we're doing that with people we're
doing that with business ideas we're
doing that with opportunities I look at
YouTube and how long it took me holy cow
how long it took me to get momentum
because I was judging it
not judging a platform but judging
myself that someone like me can't do it
because I'm introverted because I'm shy
because only people with a big ego get
in front of a camera all of these things
I was just in a no business I would say
no I was saying no I was saying no I was
saying no and listen I I'm not perfect I
still say no on things that I'm trying
to get better at
if you haven't found the thing that
you're passionate about that excites you
that drives you that pushes you forward
you're not going to find it sitting on
the couch
judging yourself and doing the same
things that you have been doing
right you do the exact same things you
have been doing for the past year your
life doesn't change in the next year
right you gotta explore got to say yes
and that takes courage and that takes
jumping through some discomfort and it
just says the ability to say yes on
things
so I was recently hanging out with Tom
bilyu and Dave Hollis and a bunch of
friends in in Napa in my biggest
takeaway
was I want to move faster on things I
want to move faster on new things it's
so easy to get locked into what you're
currently doing you know what I need to
move faster on things and so I came home
and I went faster on learning crypto I
went faster on learning about life
insurance and investing I went faster on
creating my Discord server I went faster
on all the ideas that I had it's like
okay imperfect start just build momentum
and go and now Discord has been a big
part of my daily routine I've adjusted
my entire
schedule to start my day in Discord I
went from spending zero time on Discord
not understanding what it was not
understanding a little the graphics and
what mods did and all the roles and all
of the stuff the lingo and all of the
terminology language I didn't know any
of it
to now I spend
the first chunk of my time every morning
on Discord
if you want to join us it's free Evan
carmichael.biz come come and come and
join in it's such a great way to start
my day
because I love the community because I
love connecting with people when I when
I go to events my favorite thing is to
hang out in the hallway and talk to
people and that's basically what Discord
is you get to hang out in the hallway
and talk to people and help them and
spread love and we've said so many
amazing people
and the point of that is I
now have this new thing in my calendar
that I love and I look forward to it's
like I can't wait to go back and say hi
to everybody even though I'm shy and
introverted it feels weird but a month
ago I wasn't doing it at all and it
could have easily been the thing that I
said no to that I said you know I'm so
busy I have YouTube and I have I have my
other channels and I have my team and I
have right all the stories we tell
ourselves as to why we can't do it it's
being in the no business how do you know
until you try
how do you know if your great idea is
great unless you try or if it sucks
unless you try and you're gonna love
something unless you try how do you know
if you're gonna love that person unless
you try don't know until you try
so so what are some practical steps okay
number one when you get an idea that
comes into your head trust it
I wish I could X
oh I've got this cool idea for me to why
do it just trusted the idea is a good
idea trust that it's good it's for you
it's meant for you especially if you're
in a positive environment you're
watching a video like this or you're
right in the van you're talking to
somebody and you have positive vibes
it's like I want to go make this trust
that that idea is good get out of the no
business and just start building some
immediate momentum so trust that good
ideas flow through you good ideas great
ideas extraordinary ideas flow through
you trust that
trust that and do something about it
because we don't want to wait another
year and another year and another year
and you're still sitting on these ideas
because someone like you can't do it
right so one trust that great ideas flow
through you and do something about it
two tied in the service right your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggle the most with is what you
want to help other people through so tie
that to service your passion is
something that you'll love helping other
people with so it's not just about you
if it's your own passions that's just a
hobby right something you love doing for
yourself great that's just a hobby but
ultimately we all want to feel important
we all want to feel not from an
egotistical point of view from a it's
wired into us from a human point of view
we want to feel like we matter we want
to feel like we're going to do something
today that will have an impact on other
people we are connected to each other
and so your your passion will tie into
your purpose your purpose comes in your
pain whatever you struggle the most with
is what you want to help other people
through
so inside of that
helping the you from five years ago or
ten years ago what do you need to do
what are some of the the steps that you
can sit there and help the you from five
years ago
that will be a part of your passion to
wake up and feel like I'm doing this
that's fun
that's exciting for me it doesn't feel
like work but it's also having an impact
it has to tie to service that has to if
you wanted to fill you up for the rest
of your life it has to tie to service
and it's not just this one you know
short timeline thing just to help you
feel good it has to help other people
feel good as well somehow so number one
is trust a great ideas flow through you
two tie at the surface you feel like
you're helping other people it's going
to make a big big difference and then
number three
is pay attention to things that make you
scared
pay attention to things that make you
scared and teach yourself that you do
difficult things so a lot of times
an idea might come to you or somebody
might suggest something for you and the
immediate thing that comes to mind is
this is difficult or your heart's beaten
I call it the boom boom boom test where
your heart's going boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom because you're nervous
because you're you're afraid of doing
that thing
often your your next amazing passion is
on the other side of all those things
that you're afraid of
because you're afraid that it's not
going to work or you're afraid that it's
going to disappoint people you're afraid
that it will work you're afraid of
you're afraid of failure and you're
afraid of success you're afraid of
judgment you're afraid of rejection
you're afraid you're afraid you're
afraid you're afraid you're afraid
you're afraid
but you don't find your passion by
staying afraid
find it by saying yes
so the things that are making you afraid
the things that make your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom like
that
trust it
and try it
expect it to suck expect not to get any
results
expect your first shot to miss that's
okay what's more important than if you
got the result is that you enjoy the
process
did you have fun doing it are you
excited to go back and do it again
you've got
a great gift inside you
you know you're capable of more you know
you want to serve you know you want to
help you know that you don't want to
stay stuck that's not that your life
sucks right now but you want to you want
it to be more full you want to be more
Rich you want to be in a different spot
in one year from today
and that happens by tapping into the
thing that you're passionate about
the number one rule for Success we love
the work you love the process of doing
the thing that you're doing every day
and you get that by getting out of the
no business
stop telling yourself that you can't
stop telling yourself no stop telling
yourself that someone like you can't do
it and instead flip it to say yes I'm
gonna try the thing that always helped
me make breakthroughs was getting a role
model and and learning from somebody
else and every time whether it's my
first business or getting started out on
YouTube just like with YouTube it was
Steve and finally listening to my agent
Steve that I started to grow and I did
five years like I'm in year five of my
YouTube channel I'm I still have 2 000
subscribers right so it's like I it took
if this was not an overnight success if
people want to see my growth I put it on
the website like year over year how how
much I grew or you know how much I grew
which is like nothing so uh not
naturally talented and anytime I try to
do something by myself it just didn't
work but whenever I sought out Role
Models mentors even virtually even
listening to watching videos reading
books Etc uh I would I would have
success so I just wanted to try to share
that more with the world and when I meet
somebody with Integrity you know like
like you it's like man like we got to
get Chucks up to the world dude what how
is this guy not making content your
environment creates your energy
when you are at home and you are down
and you're out and you just stay home
and you never get any fresh air and you
never get people around you to push you
and make you feel like things are
possible then you stay stuck
and when you get outside or when you go
to an event and when you meet people
even if you're not there to learn even
if you haven't picked up anything at
that event just the fact that you got
out and you met people and you changed
your environment and you got some
sunshine can make a world of difference
it is
incredibly difficult to be an
entrepreneur
it's hard
it's hard not just in that you're you
know not seeing results at the beginning
and you're trying to figure out how to
make money but it's also hard that
you're by yourself
you know and you doubt yourself and you
have insecurities and fears and you
don't know if it's going to work out or
not
it's really hard and so when you're
stuck doing everything on your own and
then the fears and the doubts
insecurities creep in when you buy
yourself a home
that's the path down to the scary Lane
you know that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and depression and it's why a
big reason why we stay stuck and while
we start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop
and and can't stay consistent have you
ever been on that entrepreneur roller
coaster where you're motivated and
excited and things are great one day and
the next day you wake up and it's kind
of not so great anymore does that happen
to you that happened to me a lot that's
for sure in the early days I mean I quit
on my business partner because I wasn't
getting results and I just felt like a
loser felt like a total idiot because
nothing was working out
um
worst day of my life it wasn't I didn't
have the heart or the ambition to do
great things or didn't believe in the
company it's just it wasn't working out
nothing was working out and and I felt
terrible about it
and the big reason why is because I was
alone I was by myself I was alone
I didn't tell my friends I mean I guess
I had a business partner but I felt bad
talking about it with with him and
I stay stuck
and so
it took me a bunch of years to figure
out
these things that I'm about to share
with you today about some hacks that
I've used to help me maintain the
momentum so let's dive in the first is
every morning I go for a believe walk
and the believe walk is just me going
outside and sun or rain or snow here in
Canada I go for a believe walk and on
that walk
it's just a way to start my day because
no matter how great a day I might have
today tomorrow I wake up and it's
another day even today it was rough I
only slept two and a half hours or
something last night so it's a very
non-typical day energy not where it
needs to be or usually is in the morning
and so first thing let's get up
and you know give us our a little bit of
Grace it may not be as great a day as as
we usually do but I'm gonna go for my
believe walk and just getting outside
just getting some fresh air on my face
just
you know having some sun with me just
not being in my my home
already starts to lighten the mood
already starts to give me more energy
and so every day I go for a believe walk
you know unless I am just completely
incapacitated and wake up get some sun
on my face wherever I am and get my
belief walking just think about what's
the kind of day I want to have you know
what's my intention for the day and try
to set that up two try to go to events
and to the idea of you know buy tickets
to things
it could be things that you don't care
about but it could also be things that
you actually you know you're going to be
around some people and every time I go
away to an event this is why you know a
pandemic has been hard because he's just
been sitting inside but every time that
I get to go away to some kind of event
whether I learn something there or not
from the speakers or the people there I
always come back with Renewed Energy
with renewed excitement with renewed
ideas even if you just go on remember
going on vacations you know you go on a
vacation and you sit on the beach and I
hate the beach you know I hate sitting
there on the beach I'll go and sit on
the beach here one day and then all of a
sudden get bored of sitting on the beach
I want to do something and so I'm then
instantly pulling out my notebook and
coming up with ideas or reading books
and you come away refreshed even though
the goal wasn't necessarily business but
you get new ideas for your business when
you get out of your routine your your
you know the routine is great but when
you feel like you're stuck
then adding a little bit of variety to
it can really help this is the balance
that we have to do as entrepreneurs we
love variety we love new we love we love
trying all sorts of new things but if we
don't stay consistent on something we'll
never accomplish our goals but if all we
do is do the same thing constantly and
we stay consistent on doing the same
thing we end up getting bored and hating
our business and now we just bought
ourselves a job so it's that constant
balance where if you haven't had any
variety for a while you need to add more
variety in and if you haven't had
consistency for a while you need to add
more consistency with this ebb and flow
that's part of being an entrepreneur
that I think you need to build in so
just scheduling time so you have your
believe walks at least I do every every
morning to set me up for the day and
then scheduling time to be able to go
off and
just just not be at home you know
whether it's a conference or an event a
vacation just something to refresh my
mind
and then the third thing is just join a
community
it was one of the biggest things that I
missed was I had no Community I was
doing it all by myself and I'm being
introverted and being shy I don't
naturally seek out community community
and talking to people it's not something
that that is normally in my mind and I'm
nervous you know going up and talking to
people so it's harder for someone like
me and maybe someone like you to join a
community but man what a difference it
makes
I think of movement makers and this is
really the program I wish I had when I
was getting started you know movement
makers is yes advice for me and we meet
every two weeks and talk about your the
movement you're trying to build and
everything you're trying to create but
more than that is a connection Community
to each other that
if you want to be a thought leader you
are not by yourself think about what
you're trying to do if you think of what
I was trying to do like I'm the only one
who I know who's trying to do this you
know who are your friends who are trying
to make YouTube videos who else is
walking through this Mom making content
right nobody so who do you know who's
doing what you want to do probably
nobody and who who do you know who's
doing what you want to do at a high
level who's ambitious and hungry
probably nobody right like you are
probably the one who is the most kind
optimistic ambitious person around you
and so when you start to get around
other people who are like that as well
man what a huge difference it makes and
so you can look at movement makers if
you want to be a thought leader but just
in general to find a community find a
community of people who are doing the
thing that you are trying to do even if
they haven't done it yet but they're
ambitious and they're hungry and they're
trying to do it
change your life
certainly business is really hard and
you know this if you're watching this
video you made it this far you know what
you know it's hard
the environment that you're around
is only partially supporting you and
when you can shake it up when you can
get outside and go for walks get some
sun on your face when you can get out of
your home and go to events and just be
around other people who are doing things
and when you can join a community of
people who are trying to do something
similar to what you're doing it can make
all the difference in the world you've
got a great idea
you're doing it for the right reason
you've got a noble cause and if you feel
like you have those energy dips where
one day you're on top of the world and
it's all exciting and then the next day
you kind of wake up and you're you're in
a rut
if that right continues on you know for
for days or weeks it's a sign not that
you're on the but this isn't the right
for you it's just a sign that you need
to add a little more variety and remind
yourself of who you are step number one
is cut out negativity just cut out the
people who don't serve you sometimes
those are friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university you're in the Friendship out
of convenience now there's a lot of
people who you might need to let go of
you might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've walked
your parallel path together and now
they've gone out well they've probably
just stayed here while you've gone out
here they don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that becomes toxic
even if you're trying to be a beacon
even if you're trying to be the person
who pulls everybody up if all you're
doing is trying to pull other people up
and there's nothing pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like this is new skin none of you
that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
say I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life the editing Almost
Doesn't Matter
like why are people listening to you
because like if we think about quality
content it people default the production
quality like oh what microphone using
their Rory and what's your headset and
like what's the lighting but nobody's
watching your stuff for your microphone
so the quality isn't production quality
it's quality of thought
can you teach me to think like you think
and so the mistake a lot of people make
is they if they're doing it themselves
at the beginning a lot of people do this
you spend 20 minutes uh making a video
and then five hours editing it
you're training the wrong skill
you're training yourself to learn an
editing software as opposed to training
yourself to be a better speaker where
your ultimate goal should be to be a
better speaker train spend five hours
making a video and 20 minutes editing it
or zero time editing it because the
ability to communicate your message in
front of a camera will be a skill set
you use for the rest of your life
whether YouTube exists or not when we're
beaming into your your living room in VR
and eight Holograms and all that you're
still just talking with camera
and so that ability to get your message
out there is the thing to train and
practice so I wouldn't worry about
editing being the most important thing
train yourself to be a great speaker
train yourself to press record deliver a
fire message and then release that as a
video because when you when I go live on
a podcast like this when I get up on
stage when I'm doing interviews there's
no edits I mean maybe if I really mess
up Rory will do me a solid and like cut
out that piece but you get on stage
there's no edits like you can't train
yourself as if you're a speaker you
can't train yourself to only communicate
when you're perfectly edited
yeah so we have to train ourselves to be
great it doesn't mean that you
completely disrespect the editing but my
goal would be to hey let's get your
business up to the point where the
content is helping you generate enough
money whether it's through your coaching
or your books or your programs so that
then you can afford to hire an Editor to
take it to the next level but the
editing will not save you it's quality
of thought more than production quality
your environment is keeping you where
you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them all
of them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years I've said Edwin you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened how do I get that
for myself right people wanted it as
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
that the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker
then the fastest way to do it is to
change your environment
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there most of the things that I guess
other people might see is failure I
don't say it's failure what's a failure
I really didn't do well like I choked on
a hair while I was talking and I guess a
lot of the things that most people would
see is failure I don't see as failure I
don't even see this feedback it just was